did you get into this
so the reason why i decided to become a
a plastic surgeon was it happened to me
in grade school
so when i was in grade school there was
a girl in my class who had a cleft lip
and palette deformity
and she was on my bus room and kids
would torture her
it was unfortunate but especially back
then because you know now we're very
focused on anti-bullying and like you
can't get away with the behavior that
used to happen when i was a kid
but people would throw things at her and
they would you know alter
you know nobody would go near her they
would you know it was because she had a
facial disfigurement unfortunately
and i was her friend i used to sit on
the bus with her
and the thing is that she had surgery
during time that i knew her and as her
appearance started to morph and become
more normalized
people started to respond to her
differently
and i thought that was a very powerful
thing
welcome to episode 142 of the michaela
peterson podcast i'm michaela peterson
i'm backstage at one of dad's show in
denver
as you can see
this episode covers plastic surgery the
real secret to staying young
i mean there's also sleeping right and
diet hello low carb and sneaky tricks
like nad but if you see a 70 year old
and they look like they're 50 it's
plastic surgery
dr andrew jacono is a world-renowned
facial plastic surgeon based in new york
city author and creator of made a
minimally invasive
hybrid facelift the secret behind
celebrities ability to never age i've
always found plastic surgery fascinating
if you look younger do you feel younger
if you feel younger do you live longer
i don't know
andrew's the founder of the new york
center for facial plastic and laser
surgery and the co-founder of thai a
non-profit organization that helps
children in third world countries get
free plastic surgery for things like
hair lips
life-changing surgeries he's been named
one of america's top plastic surgeons by
harper's bazaar the consumer's research
council of america and super doctors he
starred in the tv show facing trauma as
a volunteer surgeon for victims of abuse
dr jocono has been featured on good
morning america anderson and cnn to name
a few as well as many publications like
the huffington post and gq
his main clients are lawyers and ceos in
new york as well as celebrities and the
average person who knows about this
stuff
we talked about the ramifications of
social media the type of person who does
plastic surgery the dangers the morality
and more i hope you enjoyed this
conversation
this episode was sponsored by paleo
valley
we need collagen it's like the glue that
holds our body together we're talking
about plastic surgery in this episode
but i did mention diet is playing an
important role in aging after we hit 20
we begin to produce less and less
collagen a simple way to get a good dose
of collagen is paleo valley's bone broth
protein something i can actually eat
it's made in a pesticide free
environment and made from 100 grass-fed
bones not hides like a lot of other
products
it's also delicious you can add it to
smoothies bake dishes your coffee or
just mix it with hot water and a bit of
salt like me adding collagen to your
diet will not replace a face lift but it
certainly won't hurt i absolutely love
it it's kind of like coffee
if you haven't tasted coffee in years
it's great and it's on sale now at paleo
valley dot com with code mp for 15 off
your first order that's paleovalley.com
code mp for 15
off i hope you enjoy this episode
[Music]
dr andrew dracono welcome to my podcast
thanks for having me i'm super excited
to talk to you
yeah this is going to be fun i think i
think what you do is something everybody
should know about so before we get
started can you give a brief background
about who you are and what it is you do
sure
so my name is andrew jacono
i'm a facial plastic and redestructive
surgeon and i practice on park avenue in
new york city
and i specialize in facial aesthetic
surgery so
um things that are to enhance people's
appearance
both aesthetically to make them
achieve their you know their goals for
their beauty but also to rejuvenate the
facial appearance to make people look
younger
and as i get older this becomes more
important to me
okay so i want to cover a bunch of
things i want to cover like what you do
and then how many people actually do
this kind of thing because i think
people don't talk about it and then some
of the ethics behind plastic surgery so
that's what we're gonna kind of get into
um
so first off yeah
how many what percentage of your clients
do you think are women versus men like
how how frequent do men come in
yeah i mean at this point it's changed a
lot so i think that you know the modern
era and how aware we are of our
appearance and that's been obviously
accelerated by
you know digital cameras you know our
social media presence you know using uh
you know digital platforms to be able to
communicate work
men have embraced plastic surgery at
rates that i've never seen before i've
been doing this over 20 years
and i would say that 20 years ago that
males comprised about 10 of my practice
but today it's fully a third so that's a
lot you know it's one out of every three
people that i operate on are male
patients
yeah wow okay
again it's not surprising because
everybody wants to put their best face
forward and the reality is is that our
face is our calling card
you know in the modern era before
somebody even meets you they google you
they look at your images
they look at your social media content
and they make judgments about who you
are how effective you are at your job
and they get a sense of your personality
by the way you look and that's what we
do i mean it may not be correct
but the truth is is that today we judge
a book by its cover and it's not right
but it's it's the natural tendency
because we live in a very visual world
now
yeah especially with social media so
how
let's see what age do you think your
average patient is
well my my age definitely tilts younger
i mean older in the younger in the older
age category i should say you know i
specialize mostly in aging face surgery
so that means that i tend to take care
of people as their appearance starts to
change as they get older
in the past that would probably i would
say that that would be an average age of
somewhere in the mid 50s
but today it's really patients primarily
in their 40s
so people are embracing enhancing their
appearance at a much younger age today
than they did 20 years ago in my
practice
obviously you know there are patients
who come in who are young who have a
desire to change their nose or their
lips or their facial shape because it's
it's disproportion or imbalance you know
like a young girl who's 18 years old who
unfortunately got her grandpa's nose you
know like the whole family has a big
nose so she looks more masculine more
like male members of her family and they
she wants a rhinoplasty those obviously
will be younger patients but on average
i'd say that somebody in their mid-40s
at this point early to mid-40s
okay and
what kind of procedures do you do like
what's your what's the main what's let
me let me rephrase this question
actually if somebody wants to have a
surgery to look younger what is it that
makes people look younger
yeah so
the thing is is that it's not one thing
so this is really the artistic aspect of
what i do
is that there are multiple things and
it's different for every face
that create a more useful appearance
and so as a result you know it's often
multiple procedures it's not one big
procedure and that's what i try to
stress the patients it's not like a big
facelift or a big brow lift or lots of
eyelid surgery what makes people look
youthful is not a lot of surgery it's
little bits and details throughout the
different portions of the face
and that's what makes people look
youthful but also natural
and normal because obviously the biggest
fear is is that we're going to do
plastic surgery and we're going to look
like a freakazoid
you know people don't want to look like
interest celebrities that they've seen
who've had plastic surgery they want to
look like themselves potentially a
little bit more enhanced but arguably
like they did maybe 10 or 15 years ago
so the thing is that often for me when
i'm doing a procedure it's a combination
of things the thing that i'm most well
known for
is for doing face lifting surgery so
it's called a deep plane facelift it's a
procedure that i pioneered and i lecture
that all over the world i publish
textbooks on it but with that is often
things that are done like a temporal
lift to rejuvenate the upper brow
eyelid surgery to help smooth contours
lip lifts because unfortunately as we
age the lip groups and the upper lip
becomes elongated fat grafting to add
volume to places in the face where
people get sunk in as they get older so
it's really an artistic endeavor what
i'm doing is i'm looking at the face and
i'm contributing creating contour and
balance
and that's what makes people look young
so it's kind of a difficult question to
answer and i apologize that the answer
was so long
well that makes that makes sense though
um
so when you do these procedures do
people come in and they have a whole
bunch of things done at one time or do
they come in every six months
yeah it really depends on the
personality and the patient
what i definitely notice is that most
patients do i'd say 70 to 80 percent of
patients do it all at one time
and i think that's just because of the
you know the recovery time required you
know if people are going to go and take
that much time away from their normal
life for recovery i.e social activities
work all those things they don't want to
have to you know have seven
seven seven to ten day recoveries they'd
rather try to see if it can be done at
one time but those are busy people who
have lots going on in their lives and
then there are other people where
they're not so motivated they have a lot
of free time and they'd like to chip
away
and do a couple of procedures at a time
or one thing at a time there's no right
answer um you know you can do it either
way but i think that in modern and
modern era and you know what we're
dealing with people want to be able to
get things done and then be able to move
on with their lives and enjoy the
outcomes of the surgery not make it a
project that's going to take them two
years to get through you know and 10
weeks of recovery they'd rather be like
going you know say bart's for a you know
a vacation versus you know sitting home
and recovering and being bruised for
that period of time
so did you say seven to 10 days
on average most most recoveries for most
of these procedures you can get out
about seven to ten days afterwards it
doesn't mean you want to be you know
hosting a dinner party in your home with
people that you don't want to know about
surgery but functionally the majority of
my patients even professional patients
physicians attorneys people or financial
bankers they get back client facing or
in front of people at around 10 days i
tell them if they can get two weeks it's
ideal
but you know it's hard so you can cheat
it in 10 days and we have ways of making
the recovery much faster today that just
weren't available 10 years ago so i have
things that i can do
you know techniques and instruments and
and you know and lasers that help
recovery get rid of bruising you know
there are different treatments that we
do one of them is hyperbaric oxygen
treatments where you go into a
hyperbaric oxygen chamber every day and
increases the blood supply and the
oxygen content of the tissue so the
healing is much faster
and i've learned these things because a
lot of my patients
need to be back in front of cameras
really quickly i take care of a lot of
people who have public faces and as a
result i needed to figure out a way to
get them back to work quicker because
they don't have a lot of down time
between you know shooting you know
shooting television shows or other
things you know
what percentage of celebrities are
people who have tv appearances who are
you know in their 50s or 60s have had
work done do you think
oh so pretty much everybody who's post
who's 15 above has had work done
so if somebody men too
yeah men kind of can cheat until about
late 50s early 60s so there's definitely
an unfair um you know unfair disparity
between men and women in terms of the
way they age
women generally speaking around 50 start
to age more rapidly and by 52-53 their
face really changes
that's because women go through
menopause on average at about 50 to 51
years of age and within two years of
that change the facial tissues drop so
unfortunately there is a big change and
a shut-off that happens for women that
accelerates their aging process so on
average
most women will consider this if they
don't aren't more proactive about doing
it around 50 because they notice that
things just don't hold up nicely the way
they used to
men get to get a pass it's usually
around 60 that this stuff really starts
to come apart so i usually treat most
men later 50s to early 60s and most
women later 40s to early 50s
so that's when i kind of see it but if
you see a celebrity
who's in her early to mid 50s and she
looks youthful she's had surgery
it's nobody escapes this unfortunately
i've been doing this for 20 years and
i've done about 4 000 facelifts
nobody escapes this and it doesn't mean
that they look abnormal because with
good surgery people look natural like
themselves but youthful
but you can't be 53 years old and look
like you're 40 without surgery it
doesn't happen
okay so it's not all olive oil then
okay i don't want to comment on that but
it's not a olive oil
i guess i just did
olive oil it's not in regular i mean you
know i i give these excuses to my
patients you know when they say well
what am i going to say when people tell
me how great i look i said well if you
look natural you want to say anything
you tell people you lost weight you've
been drinking green juice you know
you've been doing more meditation people
associate a youthful but natural
appearance with good health
so it's very easy to blame it on things
like olive oil your diet your
antioxidant drinks your your vitamins
you know a new skincare regimen because
if you look normal
nobody really gets it it's only when you
have the distortion
and the classic look that comes with you
know more antiquated
facelift surgery or plastic surgery that
it gets a big alarm
so i give people these excuses all the
time like yeah just tell people that you
did these three things you know or that
you had a little bit of botox or you had
someone that you know intense pulse like
there be treating your dermatologist's
office it totally throws people off
because they're not really looking at
surgery
they're looking at somebody who looks
good and healthy and youthful and they
want to know what your secret is but
they don't think it's surgery they think
it's lifestyle choices
okay so what are the what are the
downsides here
like is is this type of thing super
invasive is it dangerous and does do you
need to go under general anesthetic no
so we don't use your anesthesia at least
i don't a lot of surgeons do but we do
something called twilight sedation which
is where you get a little iv they give
you some medicine
that just makes you kind of sleep but
you're not paralyzed with the two of
your lungs breathing gas so it's not
something where it's like a heavy
anesthesia that's very risky um
obviously all surgery has risks so it's
not risk-free but the thing is is that
when you're with an experienced
practitioner your risk of having a
significant complication from surgery is
probably less than one percent and even
then those problems if you have one can
be managed and remedied remain required
for another surgery but you know nothing
is risk-free but it's not super risky
you know we obviously have advanced our
techniques
we have advanced instrumentation that
keeps people safe and if you can do it
with less anesthesia and you can do it
in a more minimally invasive way which
we do you know old procedures had huge
incisions all around the face
you know they peel everything off and it
was a bigger deal now we can work
through smaller incisions you know with
our technology
and we can do it in a less aggressive
and less invasive way that's less risky
but also makes people look more natural
the downside is it's surgery you know
it's not risk-free there is a recovery
you know it's not comfortable you know
we have the surgery there's pain
involved you know it's it's scary you
know and you know that's the truth but
when you get to that point where you
have a resolve about what you what you
want
for your appearance and how you want to
project your appearance to the world
you know people kind of accept those
things and they get through it and you
know after a couple weeks it's like
it's not that big a deal and then you
get to enjoy the benefits of it for a
very long time
interesting
okay
are there techniques for anti-aging that
aren't surgical that you could recommend
like does botox botox work do fillers
work are there lasers that can resurface
skin like does anything else work are
there creams
yeah there's lots of stuff for sure good
skincare is always wonderful and
important but from a skin care
perspective the most important thing
from my perspective and i don't
prescribe skin care and i have good
dermatology colleagues that work in
cosmetic dermatology that i refer to
but the primary thing that i think
that's important is you should be on is
some kind of a retin-a or a vitamin a
derivative and those are skin creams
um retinol is like an example of it but
retinol is not that strong but
prescriptive retin-a
thickens the collagen laser of your skin
and it prevents aging it actually
supports thickness of the skin and the
pro layers that tend to thin out as we
get older so that's a really important
thing to do and it's something that
people should do throughout their life
because it definitely will help minimize
how much the skin falls and wrinkles so
that's one thing botox is wonderful
because when you put botox in if you're
not flexing your face all the time you
don't develop lines and wrinkles in the
forehead around the eyes it helps
support the brows so it prevents aging
so botox even though it can be costly
over a very long period of your life
because if you started younger say in
your mid to late 30s and you continued
on with it for a long time it gets
expensive
but is it worth yes it is
fillers you have to be very careful with
and i talk about this a lot lecture all
over the world about it the problem with
fillers is they create something called
the tissue expansion effect
and what that means is as you put filler
in you stretch the tissues out
when you stretch the tissues out it's
like a pregnant woman when they have a
pregnant belly they lose the pregnant
belly there's a lot of skin that gets it
develops and it hangs
so a lot of women get tummy tucks
because the skin has been so stretched
out after pregnancy
similarly with fillers if you overdo
fillers you will stretch your face out
and if you do that it'll actually make
it drop more quickly
so one of the big problems that i deal
with in my practice is women who started
phyllis too young
because they thought they were
preventing their aging but they stretch
their face out so they need a facelift
much younger
than they probably would have sometimes
by even a decade
so fillers are good
when done with small quantities with
them with an even hand but when you
start blowing things up too much
unfortunately this could be a
significant problem
[Music]
wow that's something people should
really know about because they're you go
on instagram and it's like oh do the you
know kylie jenner package or something
and it's yeah well yeah it's easy to
market and it's simple it's not surgery
it's just a couple of injections and
sometimes it can look really good
but the problem is is how frequently you
do it and how much you do it one time
because it can look good the first time
in the second time but sometimes after
people doing it the fourth fifth or
sixth time as they continue to age
they're putting more and more stuff in
to try to recreate the same effect but
our aging face doesn't recreate the same
effect with the injections that it did
say five years ago seven years ago so
people try to use more to get what they
used to get but then all they do is they
stretch their face out
okay and you mentioned something about
fat grafting
so
what's the difference between that and
just having a facelift
so fat grafting is just like using
filler it's just using your own body fat
so the thing is is that any place where
you can use filler you can do something
more permanent with fat
similarly
fat can cause the same problems that
fillers can so it has to be done evenly
and not too much
but the other problem is is that if you
put a lot of fat in the face
it can weigh the face down because it
has more weight than filler does
so similarly with time and age fat
grafting tends to drag the face down
because it's like strapping two weights
into the face
so all these things are a matter of
degree
but it's more common for me not to do
fat grafting in younger patients and
here's the reason why
fat is a hormonally active tissue
so when women go through changes and
start to have hormonal changes as they
age
a lot of women start to gain a little
bit of weight and it's not
because they're not trying hard but it's
a lot easier to stay thin when you're 20
than when you are when you're in your
mid to late 40s right for everybody
the problem is that the fat that you put
in the face acts like the fat from your
belly
so if you start to put weight on in your
body because your metabolism is changed
guess what happens to the fat in your
face
it grows
so what i see is i see a lot of women
who are fat grafting in their 30s whose
faces now are getting big and distortive
and they weren't like that when they
were younger because the fat
was one size but as they put weight on
the fat in the face grows like as if it
was in the belly
because it grow it behaves like where it
came from not where it was placed
so the face gets very distorted so for
me fat grafting i prefer to use it in
patients who are older who have already
been through some of those metabolic
changes versus trying to use it as a
substitute for fillers fellows can be
dissolved away
fat cannot so when you have a problem
with fat grafting it becomes a big
surgical problem
that a lot of people would prefer to
avoid and you learn these this is the
thing
when you do so much of this and i've
done so many thousands of surgeries i've
made a lot of mistakes and i've learned
from those mistakes over the years
that's what happens that's what good
surgeons do
so as a result
i know how to avoid more of those
problems for my patients and i know who
the right patients are to direct to what
treatments in what amounts at what time
in their life
that's wild that you can graft belly fat
or something like that and then it'll
gain weight like belly fat that's crazy
i bet people didn't expect that that's
where it came from it doesn't change its
character
we're using it to like resupplement but
it has the character of where it came
from
wow
okay
that's very cool okay so
now that we have a bit of a background
about all this
actually no one question first so you
said facelifts used to be
a lot scarier than they are and you used
to end up with just like scars
everywhere
yeah very visible scars
and very long incision lines so you it
would be very very hard to camouflage
against the surgery you know you'd have
to kind of wear your hair down and hide
everything as much as you could and if
you ever had to go get your hair cut or
jump in the pool everybody would see
these horrible scars
everywhere which is not fun nobody wants
i mean even if you look good you don't
want to have
a visible telltale sign anywhere you
don't even want your face to look normal
but you also don't want to have you know
visible scars that tell everybody where
you've been and what you've done
mm-hmm so what's the difference between
that and now like how come there are so
many older celebrities that are in their
60s that look absolutely fantastic and
they don't look like they have any scars
or people can't tell otherwise they'd be
you know all over the magazines because
they've had good surgery you know
you know arguable there are lots of
great surgeons out there when somebody's
at like an award show and everybody's
like holy crap what happened to that
person
knows they had you know not a great
procedure and they probably had a
technique and you know an approach
that was you know used decades ago but
that still happens a lot
you know there's a good and high
percentage of patients who go to doctors
who have those techniques and then there
are more evolved techniques and
unfortunately probably a smaller
percentage of surgeons are educated and
capable with those techniques
but those are the people that you see
who are six years old and celebrity and
you're like she looks great like you
don't say oh my god she looks ex-age you
just like look at her and you can't even
perceive her age because she just looks
fantastic
that's the beauty of the classic spirit
i've always wondered if
there was any correlation between
looking younger and
and age length age span i don't know if
or lifespan i don't know if they've done
any studies on that but i've talked to
people who've had procedures done who've
look who look now 15 years younger and
they say they feel younger too
yeah i definitely think that there's
health benefits
but i think it's because
when people look better
and they're more prideful of their
appearance
they tend to lead healthier lifestyles
so people who have a better more
youthful looking face will often
exercise more they'll eat more you know
more carefully
because they want this to match this
so i think that it sets in motion habits
that make people live a longer and
potentially healthier life for sure
so that's where i think the link is i
don't think it's generated in the brain
i think it's generated by habit that's
just reinforces better habits and i've
seen it over and over again i do a
procedure on a patient and then i see
them six months later and they've lost
25 pounds they look fantastic
because they're like well this looks
great like before
you know my body wasn't my concern
because my face really didn't look great
now this looks fantastic and now my body
becomes my concern you know because i
want it all to look great together
so that's where i think that comes in
okay that's very interesting
and then how do you feel about
the ethics of
of how popular it's become to surgically
enhance yourself and like i guess the
costs associated with that and whether
or
not
certain people can't afford them richer
people can't afford it and i don't know
the morality
yeah you mean you know
it's a very hard thing to
you know
i mean i guess it really comes down to
your to your politics in a lot of ways
right i mean if you're more of an
egalitarian
you get tweaked by it because you feel
like it's unfair that people who have
more money have access to this because
the truth is unfortunately is that
because we judge a book by it by its
cover when people are more youthful more
attractive their lives tend to be better
and i know that firsthand
they get more job opportunities they
have better relationships they have more
confidence it builds
a positive spin on their life
and it's it's effective
for sure and it's not the reason why
people do surgery but lots of things
evolve in a very positive way when
somebody who suddenly looks 20 years
younger like if you're 60 years old
people tend to think of you differently
you know how effective you are in your
workplace
how friendly you are you know people as
they get older they look sad they look
angry they look less approachable people
avoid you
you know you go out in public and you
look 40 all of a sudden the whole world
seems to open up
so
it's not
you know fair
that people who have more means get that
so i think that if you're more of that
camp
then i think you haven't you have you
feel like there's an ethical
uh dilemma there
i don't really think that's the case
you know for me
um there are ways for people to have
surgery and you don't have to have a ton
of money
you know there are lots of options for
surgeons surges charge different prices
there's ways to finance surgery just
like you would a car
you know
by a hyundai and i would tell you that
you can probably get a pretty good
surgeon if you finance the cost of a
hyundai and i would arguably say that
you know the the
value to the person in terms of quality
of life is probably more valuable than
hyundai depending on where you are
and what you're trying to achieve
so there's ways of getting it done you
don't have to be ultra rich
in order to be happy to be able to have
plastic surgery and you know the the
question is is that why do you know why
does it matter so much
and should we value appearance as much
as we do
and that's the hard part
you know because for me
i have four children
you know
and the thing is is that as a parent
it's not like i think everybody should
have a type of face i don't think
everybody should have perfect balance
symmetry and beauty
there's a lot of beauty in not having
all those things
um but you know
it's like trying to tame the beast at
this point
because of our our our uh our
visualization
of beautiful people and youthful people
and how it's you know pushed on us
it really is and we've sponsored eggs
that pop up all the time
you know everywhere we go
you know we're aspiring to look a
certain way there's a celebrity we
analyze there's all this constant visual
imagery
and that it's not great you know because
it makes us feel inadequate it makes us
feel less than
you know and unfortunately it creates a
certain dysphoria
that drives people to have plastic
surgery
but unfortunately i don't think it's
plastic surgery that's driving it it's
not surgeons like me who are creating
the need or want it to happen
but we're serving
you know
we're providing a service
to help people manage the modern era
and i don't like it even though it's
what i do for a living right so it's
what i do and i love doing it and i make
people happy doing it
i think it's an unfortunate side effect
of the society we live in
and one of the big things for me when it
comes to that is i feel like social
media companies need to be held
responsible for their behavior
and that's something that i know right
now
is very much important
because the truth is is that if social
media companies are held accountable for
their behavior
you can't sue a social media company
so if they do heart
marvel about ourselves there's no
recourse
but what they do is they manipulate
content they drive it in front of us
they make people feel horrible
there's tons of studies that show
that the number of younger people who
are adolescents and young adults who
feel inadequate who have poor self-image
and body image because of social media
it is a problem
and the thing is is that they curate
content and they know how to drive it to
you to stay keep you linked
onto their uh their their you know their
platform
and they manipulate the hell out of
everybody and it actually creates the
desire for these things more than it
would exist if we didn't have these
things around
so for me the real ethical transgression
is not in wanting the blue plastic
surgery or executing it i feel like the
platforms and the way we get information
today is so manipulated that it's
targeting us in order to make us feel
like we need to be other than who we are
and that's what frustrates me because as
a father i don't want my children to
feel like they're not adequate that
their body type isn't good enough that
their face isn't beautiful enough
because there's beauty in all shapes and
sizes but it makes us feel that way
so for me that's the big dilemma this
episode is brought to you by nordpass do
you work in the cloud have you ever
wondered what would happen if you lose
your passwords or even worse you get
hacked
business and cyber security are
inseparable nowadays everything we do is
connected to the internet stored in a
cloud so it's crucial to protect
business operations and information and
make sure you can control who can access
that information
save time secure notes not just
passwords keep track of your password
health and log in faster with nordpass
and there aren't even all the features
listed there nordpass is amazing you can
take advantage of their new huge offer
right now from march 11th get 50 off
nordpass premium plus one month free
at nordpass.com tmpp like the michaela
peterson podcast in case that needed
clarification or use code tmpp at
checkout
if you like this content please remember
to hit subscribe i saw
i don't remember where it was it might
have been a country that said they were
going to make editing your photos
illegal
right i can't remember where that's
happening but um i've seen i've seen the
impact of social media on my cousins i
have a couple of
teenage girl cousins
and it's rough because every single
person that they follow edits their
photos in ways that humans can't really
look
yeah and
they feel ugly yeah yeah but but you
know what's so funny these people have
plastic surgery
so they've had plastic surgery and then
they're editing their photos on top of
plastic surgery
so it absolutely is the case
because you feel like well what's wrong
with me
all these people look flawless shouldn't
i look that way because obviously
there's a certain
you know worship that we have for our
you know for you know the people we look
up to
you know it's you know it's in all
fields and it's in all ages you know
maybe a younger person looks up to
excuse me a um
you know
a famous person you know i look up to my
you know my heroes in my in my
professional world you know the people
that are the giants and the people that
i learned from you know who made a lot
of advances in my field so we all look
up to people but the generation
definitely looks up to people who are
more beautiful and more you know
archetypal or you know
or are the best in terms of their
appearance and it's really unfortunate
but everybody
seems to manipulate their their images
and it's so funny because you look at
these magazines sometimes and they
always have like little arrows showing
where you can see like the edges of a
photo looking all like you know janky
and like
you know the person sitting there and
their waist looks this thin but then you
see like the bricks like having a
distorted pattern around them because
they just crush the pixels
so it's like sometimes it's really goofy
and obvious
but again
you know getting bombarded with that
imagery over and over again really wears
away your brain and makes you feel
inadequate
yes bit of a pickle
it's definitely a bit of a picture yeah
but it's a pickle but i think it's a
pickle that can be solved
you know because once these companies
are held accountable for their behavior
they will change their behavior because
if you can imagine the financial
downside of a class action lawsuit of
tens of thousands of families who had
children who wound up with mental
illness or suicide it would be in the
number of trillions of dollars
but the thing is is that right now there
is no repercussions
they can do whatever they want whenever
they want and there's nothing you can
say about it
so once that happens i think that
they'll be more responsible with what
they do
and they can even enact policies where
can you know come on we have such
technology
they should have the ability to use
technology to make sure that those kind
of images are not allowed to be posted
like that's a possibility
why should that be allowed
you know if we know it's causing
significant pervasive public mental
health problems which it does
why don't we hold people accountable to
make it different
we should
that's a very good idea
that's a that's a very good idea i don't
know why
that wouldn't have been i guess
everything is so new social media is so
new it hasn't been a long around and
long enough for people to
yeah but i think the reason why is at
the end of the day is that all of these
companies all they really want
they're not concerned with ethics they
want more eyes more volume more clicks
you know and more ability to then
because of the volume of traffic be able
to sell advertising it is a business
so if a altered image gets more
attention than an unholded image
they prefer the altered image
right
because if it's going to get more views
and clicks
then that means more revenue and that's
really what they are at the end of the
day they're for-profit companies they're
publicly traded and they're motivated by
profit like all corporations are but
when it has pervasive mental health
company you know complications for us as
a society i think that we need to take a
step back and hold people accountable
for their behavior that's and this is
like getting way off target from what
plastic surgery is
but i you know because of what i do for
a living i see how devastating it can be
over long term to people young and old
do you have people come in that show you
pictures of clearly altered faces and
say i want this
absolutely
so especially younger patients they come
in with their iphone and they have like
a file of screenshots
of people whose appearance they cover
i like this nose i like my lips this way
i want this like this and this like that
and obviously you can't transplant those
things on patients so you need to be
educated and you have to go over with
them what's possible what the
limitations are because not every nose
and every face can just be made into
something
you know you can get parts of things it
has to do with what you start with
um it's not like you can just plug
things on it's a plug and chug it
doesn't work that way
but it is very very common for people to
show up with that kind of that kind of
information
to a consultation
hmm
do you have advice for people who are
potentially interested in this on how to
avoid bad surgeons
yeah i mean i think that you know
you know where we live we live in a
modern era and people have access to
information
so it's very i think it's pretty easy i
mean people do deep dives and everything
right people are going to buy a vacuum
cleaner and they go online and they read
about the vacuum cleaner they look and
read about people's online reviews and
what their experience is like with it
you know you can get a lot of
information out there
so i think that's one of the first
places to start
is by doing that kind of deep dive and
research into people you know people
have different expertise if you want a
rhinoplasty and you know you go to a
doctor you see that mostly what he does
is breast augmentation is probably not a
good idea but you know this is the kind
of information that you can get
by just spending some time
and then after you do that
um you should you know see a number of
doctors and i always say this you should
go with your gut because
you know sometimes you can be
intimidated we're in a situation where
somebody's supposed to be you know a
very you know well-known or professional
person
um but it can be difficult because
you're like well this person's supposed
to be so great i really just have them
do it but you really need to listen to
your internal compass
because you know beyond you know doing
your deep dive not every
you know doctor is going to be the right
fit for you
and obviously the doctor just doesn't
have to be a good technician but they
need to be a good person because they
need to see you through the recovery
phase of your surgery and be able to
address concerns as they as they arise
and if somebody seems to be short
arrogant you know doesn't want to answer
your questions or for just some reason
you guys don't get along
this is like a marriage
you know
you know you're you're you're this is
like oh this is almost like speed dating
like you get a sense in your gut right
away like this isn't going to work
it's not going to be any better after a
surgical treatment so i think it's
important to listen to your instincts as
well
um but you know obviously referrals from
other doctors referrals from people are
happy patients all these things are nice
but it's not always easy to find those
things so you have to be your own
detective i think in a lot of ways
why did you get into this
so the reason why i decided to become a
plastic surgeon was it happened to me in
grade school
so when i was in grade school there was
a girl in my class who had a cleft lip
and palette deformity
and she was on my bus room and kids
would torture her
it was unfortunate but especially back
then because you know now we're very
focused on anti-bullying and like you
can't get away with the behavior that
used to happen when i was a kid
but people would throw things at her and
they would you know
alter
you know nobody would go near her they
would you know it was because she had a
facial disfigurement unfortunately
and i was afraid i used to sit on the
bus with her
and the thing is that she had surgery
during time that i knew her and as her
appearance started to morph and become
more normalized
people started to respond to it
differently
and i thought that was a very powerful
thing
that's the reason why we do a plastic
surgeon wow that okay so that
because i think of who my dad is i've
done a lot of reading about different
personality types and what kind of
people become surgeons or ceos and
generally speaking from what i've read
it's very disagreeable people who are
low in compassion who become surgeons
and really go up to the higher levels of
businesses
there's a higher percentage it's not
that that's the majority of us
but like the thing is is like for
example you know the rate of sociopathy
you know people who are sociopaths who
are people who are stock brokers you
know physicians politicians
surgeons specifically is much higher
than the average person out there but it
doesn't mean it's the majority of people
who go into that profession you know
what i mean so it's a little bit skewed
but it's definitely
you know
you know
hundreds of percentages more than the
average person who has a
job that's outside of that field you
know what i mean
but there are a lot of certainties who
are very compassionate but the thing is
is that there's a lot of physicians who
need that more aggressive
personality type if you will as surgeons
you know physicians in general not
necessarily but people who are drawn to
these kinds of fields and plastic
surgery orthopedic surgery and things
like that tend to be more like that
interesting so do you still do cleft
palate do you do cleft palate surgery
yeah i do so when i don't do it in my
private practice
what i do is is i go on two missions a
year
to south america where i do congenital
birth defect surgery so i know how to do
it oh it's not my focus in my private
practice you know my passion my private
practice is doing these kinds of
rejuvenated procedures it's what i
publish you know studies on it's what i
lecture about it's you know what i do
every day
um but the thing is though is that you
know i stay true to that that one thing
that kind of got me here which is to do
that surgery you know when i go to these
countries
in an average week we'll do like about
100 kids
we will do surgery on them so i go to
quito ecuador
every year and then i go to
columbia and south america every year
and i go to the same locations because
they're endemic they have areas where
they have high
rates of these genetic birth defects so
high rates of cleft lip and palate to
form any other things
and i go there and i do it you know
twice a year for like 10 days you know
we do we have to go we have to screen
the patients we do the surgery do the
post-operative care and then we're out
and we go back every year so we can see
the kids and we have doctors back in
those countries
who will see them through their recovery
phase but we you know they don't have
the expertise to do the surgery
unfortunately and as a result you keep
going back there to do the work
that is so amazing like i've seen some
of your before and afters for cleft
palate surgery and that like you said
would completely change somebody's life
completely
well it does because like literally
within an hour procedure it's really you
know very um
it's
it's like
mind numbing i mean when you do the
procedure and you hand that child back
to their parent
looking normal again it's pretty crazy
oh wow it's pretty wild
wow okay that's fantastic i'm glad to
hear that um
okay i think another let me ask you
another question here so you talked
about lasers of bed and you said lasers
to help bruising so what kind of you've
actually seen evidence of some of this
is it low-level light therapy
no it's something called a pulse dye
laser you can't really use it yourself
it's a very expensive piece of equipment
it's called the v-beam the one that i
use
and it uses um this particular
wavelength of light to it gets absorbed
into purples and then it actually breaks
up
the body can reabsorb it so you know
it's not something you can do at home
like a light therapy or an led therapy
or something like that unfortunately it
needs to be executed by a physician with
who has this kind of equipment and most
doctors don't have it because it's you
know say a couple hundred thousand
dollars for the machine
so most people like all the bruising
will go you know for me my patients they
really need to be able to get back to
things quicker so we have a baby we
treat our patients with it you know
post-operative way to get rid of it
yeah does that does that stop any of the
healing that happens with bruising
yeah the bruising doesn't create healing
it actually makes it worse because when
you have blood that sits in the tissues
which is what bruising is it takes more
time for your body to wear away in it so
it slows down the human process so being
able to break it up with this technology
actually makes the healing faster
wow that is so cool okay that's fun and
how about these do you know anything
about the lasers people can use at home
like these low-level light therapy
lasers have you seen anything effective
or those red lights is any of that real
yeah it's for me it seems very anecdotal
so what i mean is that i have lots of
patients who do it
and they they they feel like they have
great results
you know there aren't a lot of studies
that show that it's really effective in
a way that we would look at it
scientifically as doctors
um but you know the problem with these
things is
is that there's something called the
placebo effect which most people know
and the placebo effect means i give you
a sugar pill
and it'll make people's like for example
they have high blood pressure
30 of the time it'll make your blood
pressure drop now it's just a sugar pill
but the idea in our minds our minds are
so powerful that it can really make
physical changes in our body by the mere
suggestion that it is going to be
helpful to us
so if i took these light therapies and i
gave it to 100 people
and i convinced them that it was going
to make them look better
30 of the people would actually look
better and it would have to do with
their body's reaction
through the through their mind and
change their physicality
so when we look at the effectiveness of
a treatment it needs to be greater than
the placebo effect
but most things aren't just the placebo
effect that's why we take vitamins and
we feel better
does that mean that it's better than
taking a sugar pill no but the thing is
is that 30 of the time we start a new
regimen and it sets a a neurologic
biophysical you know thing that happens
within humans that actually makes things
better so that's why i think that we get
drawn to
different remedies
whether it's drinking a tea using a
light therapy taking vitamins
you know even doing you know
you know certain types of rituals
they can make us look and feel better
and it's real so it works
but whether you should invest a lot of
money in it or not is the question it's
really that effective
you know and for me i know that that
data just isn't there for those throws
treatments but it's okay it's not bad to
try them not going to hurt you and if
you seem to benefit with them i say
continue on with them
so what does a day in your life look
like like how often are you in the
operating room how many hours do you
work when you wake up
i wake up at about 4 30 in the morning
i'm in the office early i usually start
my first surgery about six o'clock in
the morning
i try to do two surgeries a day like in
bigger surgeries you know
um i do one in the morning because you
know i take my time i take a break
and then i do my second procedure in the
afternoon
and then i usually finish with surgery
sometime in the you know the
the early evening
and then i see patients and do consult
so i have to see my patients who i've
done surgery on different phases of
healing
but i usually finish with work probably
somewhere around 80 30 90 o'clock at
night i try to work only on average
depends on the week but at this point in
my career i try to work either three or
four days a week
so i don't work five day weeks i work
and when i'm here i'm doing that
so i'm a surgeon that's what i do and
every day that i work i operate that's
what i love to do
but i don't do it i don't operate five
days a week i don't breathe six days a
week i do three days a week and then the
next week i'll do four and then i'll go
back to three
and the reason why i do that is because
in order to be able to stay focused
creative
and desirous of my profession i don't
want to be exhausted by it and i love
what i do but i also love not doing what
i do and taking time and space to be
able to focus on other aspects of who i
am as a person
actually makes me a better surgeon
so the thing is is that i like to do
lots of creative things i like to draw
pain sculpt you know i like to be
outdoors i like to do lots of stuff
but doing those things give me the space
and the ability to think about who i am
and what i do and how i do it
but being too entrenched and too focused
and working too much
it actually starts to make you sort of
lose
you know
you know
the creative process that's required to
be good at what i do for a living
because you should always be evolving
and changing
but if you're just hammering away all
the time
how can you have the time in the space
to reflect just isn't there
and then everything you do turns into an
obligation right instead of something
you want to do
yeah it becomes an obligation it becomes
a burden
you know you can work a 15-hour day
but if you love it
and you have a time for it but you have
a time away from it 15 hours is nothing
but if you're doing 15 hours a day 6 or
7 days a week it becomes a problem
so
yeah
how do you think
how do you think you're able to look at
a face and
see what could potentially enhance it or
make it look younger
yeah i mean that just comes with a
massive amount of experience
and having made a lot of bad judgment
calls
you know the reality is is that when it
comes to these kinds of pursuits and a
lot of professional endeavors there's an
old saying that i love to say over and
over again because i teach a lot of
surrogates and i have fellows that i
teach
is that
you know judgment comes from experience
and experience comes from poor judgment
it takes a lot of time
a lot of reflection
and a lot of mistakes to become
excellent what you do it doesn't just
happen it's not a matter of learning
it's a matter of the process
and as you go on you get better and
better at what you do
it's just like looking at artists over
the arc of their career because i do
think this is a very artistic endeavor
work changes so significantly throughout
the course of their their lives and
their career
there's like the early work the mid work
and then the stuff that usually is more
defining which is their way to work
and it's a it's an evolution it's a
process
so it's not like i could really teach
somebody to have my vision my vision for
what i see when i'm going to operate on
somebody
of course i try to and that's why i
write textbooks and i publish papers i
want people to be able to have
techniques and tools on their belt to
help them make them better but really
what we're doing is we're creating an
artistic endeavor when we do surgery on
patients and it's something that comes
from my brain my eyes and my reflective
experience over thousands and thousands
of patients
so as a result
it's very hard for me to explain to you
because it's not like i look at a face
and i have a formula like i measure i do
that and it's not formulaic
it's that i see things and as i see them
i can see
what's often what needs to be created
and what needs to change to create a
more natural more beautiful appearance
and of course i discuss that with the
patients like they're my canvas ladies
do whatever the hell i want
but the thing is is that
you know my hit rate is very very high
because of the fact that i've had those
experiences and i've learned from them
fascinating okay well
if people want to learn more about this
is there a website they can go to or a
book they should read where can people
find you online yeah so
a couple things so i have a book that i
published it's called the park avenue
face you can get it in bookstores or on
amazon and it goes through a lot of this
stuff it talks about techniques and
procedures what works and what does it
what things to avoid that we talked
about fillers all the stuff is in my
book it also talks about facial abortion
beauty and all you know it's it's a
little bit like a crash course but it's
very much made for the lay public
and i use it you know the language that
i use is really so that people can
engage it
as a lay person who's not a doctor
because i publish for the for physicians
but then i publish for the way public to
educate them so they can avoid making
the pitfalls and the missteps getting
treatments or surgeries that are going
to create problems for them
you know with that in mind serving the
patient so that's a great thing it's
called the parking face you get on
amazon you don't go to a bookstore
um otherwise you can find me on social
media i have a big instagram following
at dr jacono it's d-r-j-a-c-o-n-o
and then my website is
really long it's new york facial plastic
surgery dot com all spelt out no
abbreviations no periods
newyorkfacialplasticsurgery.com
and i i i got that url
you know 25 years ago when i was a
resident
so i never changed it i never will i'm
like one of those people like once i
make a decision i stick with it when it
comes to those kinds of events
it's not a bad url for what you do
yeah it's not but it's too long
there's got to be something that's more
brief catchy and rememberable but like
thinking about typing that in n-e-w
y-o-r-k f-a-c-i-l
p-l-a-s-t-f-e-s-u-r-g-r-y dot com
it's a little bit much
okay well
thank you doctor very much for coming on
my show that was enlightening it's a
very interesting topic
yeah well it was great talking to you
hopefully it didn't uh overwhelm you
with all my thoughts it's a little bit
much sometimes a little bit too much
going on up here
no no no
[Music]
you